together in this i'm sure you've heard
this
before but it almost seems like this
there couldn't be a more perfect time
for this song you know it feels
like it feels wonderful to sing a song
that just
has a good flow to it um
[Music]
you know i mean it was but without
the season that we're in you know i mean
like how could creativity not come out
of
this time actually of like inner
reflection and uh
you know staying at home with the ones
you love and it you know this it just
i think it's gonna we're gonna find a
lot of amazing um
art and you know things like that come
out of this
uh i find that it's very easy to wallow
in this time
but find it finding positivity is a
little bit more work
that's true that is true actually how do
you fight where do you find the
positivity
well my friend wrote this song so that's
one thing that really helped is it
wasn't
i didn't have to come up with that
positivity myself let me turn like
you but you have to sing it though
that's the thing you got to put yourself
in that headspace to actually perform it
to be
happy well i feel like music is one of
those things that can take you out of
the situation you're in i think that's
why it's so popular
i think that's why people like to go to
shows or festivals or you know and
unfortunately we can't do that
so i think in this time of staying home
we're all having to kind of really go
how do i get what i need without the
usual way that i
get it you know and i think um
writing songs me for me like also
listening to the songs i love um
really making an effort i do i agree
with you that it's easy to wallow in
this time
it's easy to just to kind of get cozy in
your aloneness
to get isolated but the other part of it
is i do believe that
human beings we have we we're like we're
so
social like we really do need the
connections and it's very um
probably dangerous for us to be too
isolated
um have you become an expert in children
programming and children's movies
in the last couple of years yes
it's two and a half so i'm kind of
introducing him you know things
to him very gently um but at this time
and every single mom in the world
i mean this is the crazy thing we're all
going through this at the same time
so i'm i'm pretty sure that every mom
even the ones who are like i'm never
going to let my kid watch tv
has been letting their kid watch tv or
youtube or whatever because you kind of
need
you need a break every now and then and
it becomes about your own self-care as
well as much as
educating them is jungle beat the movie
on loop in your house right now
yeah i mean it's such a wonderful movie
and it's uh
jungle beat is just it's got a lovely
positive message so it's definitely
a movie that i feel comfortable letting
my son watch and um
my friend wrote the song for it um
but you know like this is a thing like
when you have kids
it just opens up a whole new door inside
yourself
of um being able to be like a child
again you know
like my kid is playing with his toys but
really i'm playing with his toys too
um because i am a big kid and um
yeah it's really fun to sing a song that
is in a movie that my kid can watch uh
you were very
open when solomon went through his
surgeries
and you didn't have to be you didn't
have to share
um what did you what was the decision
behind that
and what did you get out of it
especially from from fans
lending their sort of their support i
in the moment when it happened you know
my son had two brain surgeries and we
were in hospital for
five weeks to la children's hospital
amazing hospital
honestly the very extremely hard thing
to go through when when your kid is in
pain and you don't know what the problem
is
um but i felt also
also quite quickly as we started to find
out what the treatment was and
like i felt very grateful because in the
hospital there's people who are much
who have much worse off problems and um
so i that made me really you know i
can't wallow
there's that word um but
um and also my son is such a sunshine
such a joy so
you know i mean i i think it's been such
a lesson in
practicing like breathing and meditating
and and again
that work like connecting with people
and i had so many incredible people just
coming around me
and and us and bringing encouragement
and um sending vitamins and like
whatever just things making soup and um
so at the time i didn't share
i didn't know how much to share at the
time that it was happening because there
was so much uncertainty
and i also want to be super conscious
that you know of
solemn and my son it's his life and who
knows what was going to happen
you know there were some times where i
was crying um
you know i was being very strong for him
and then i would go into the hotel lobby
and just be
sobbing walking around you know just
sobbing and it just feels really weird
to like then take the camera out and be
like hi guys i'm crying
you know so i'm not really that kind of
quit get the camera out my tears you
know i'm not that kind of person
where i share it like that in the real
time like
in detail but i but having gone through
this i
am now at a point and my son is healthy
i just feel i want to share because
i think that each each of us will gonna
we go through difficult things that feel
like the most difficult thing ever
um and it just feels encouraging to know
that other people are going through
things too and
i do know that there are people whatever
i think is difficult there are
guaranteed people out there who are
going through something much harder so
um hopefully i think it's just that
feeling that you're not alone
yeah it's it's it's a powerful
reminder and we all know it but
sometimes we need reminding
so you almost had like a practice run
for
covid in isolation with the time you
spent in the hospital before all this
happened
i feel like that yeah because we were
wearing masks
and it was a tiny room and entertaining
a toddler who had wires
stuck in him you know and that he could
he was trying to pull out all the time
and every time
the wires out they would have to strap
him down and poke him again and put it
back in you know so i was just like
trying to keep this
child entertained um
yeah so i i definitely felt like um
i've had a little bit of a head start i
think
um temporary tattoos i was like um
playing every kind of game in the book
and uh you know and
also letting him watch tv
he loved minions oh he did yeah
what's the number one what's the what's
the big one in your house right now
what's the
what's the movie on loop well it has to
be jungle beats
um sure so um i think one i just
discovered that my friend told me about
is called sarah and duck
super cute um yeah my um
it's english um the english influence
it's a great show uh when it comes to
you i i was so blown away where time and
i don't even know whether it's just
isolation or whatever it is
but you just start reading these things
that sort of put time into perspective
and it hit me so hard that it's been 15
years since
unwritten 15 years that's crazy
that's crazy you would probably
you're probably 17 when that came out oh
come on
and now you have beautiful gray hair
yeah i wish but what does that mean for
you what is your relationship with time
when it comes to
your art like do you think in terms of
years or do you think in terms
of projects like when you hear unwritten
in 15 years what does that mean to you
i just i feel like i'm the same age i
was when i when i did
unwritten i i um i feel like this is
weird i just feel like everyone has a
certain age that they
they they always feel like i feel like
i've always been 27
even when i was a kid like so yeah
i don't know i just like everyone has an
age like i i feel like i've got i've
i feel more like taking risks and more
young now that i'm older when i was
young i was quite serious kid um
so unreal oh man i mean to write a song
to co-write a song that uh
just impacts people like that it's such
a blessing actually for
the people who write it it's it's such a
it's an amazing thing and i think that
i've always seen myself as a songwriter
as a conduit like i just i
i'm there and the song flows through me
and um
and it's also about the interaction of
the other people in the room i always
co-write i write with other people and
and that's because there's there's there
is like sparks that fly
with different people and different
experiences that's just
fascinating and fun